ASSEMBLY MEMBER WICKS NOTICES
THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM.
THE SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL
PREPARE THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN
THE ABSENT MEMBERS AND THE CLERK
WILL CALL THE ROLL.
AGUIAR-CURRY ARAMBULA.
BAUER-KAHAN BERMAN BIGELOW.
BLOOM BURNER FOR VAST.
BONTA.
BRO [inaudible]
BURKE.
CALDERON CARRILLO CERVANTES CHAU.
CHEN DAVID CHIU.
CHOI KANSEN CHU COOLEY COOPER.
CUNNINGHAM DALLY.
DAILY DEEP [inaudible]
EGGMAN FLORA FONG.
FRAZIER FRIEDMAN GABRIEL
GALLAGHER CRISTINA GARCIA
EDUARDO GARCIA.
GIPSON GLORIA GONZALEZ AS GRAY.
GRAYSON HOLDEN.
IRWIN JONES SAWYER CHOLERA
KAMLAGER-DOVE.
KILEY LACKEY LEVINE LOAN.
LOW MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS MAYES
MCCARTY MEDINA MELENDEZ MULLIN
MURATSUCHI NAZARIAN OBERNOLTE
O'DONNELL PATTERSON
PETRIE-NORRIS QUIRK.
QUIRK SILVA RAMOS RAY IS THREE
OF US ROBERT RIVAS RODRIGUEZ.
RUBIO SALAS SANTIAGO SMITH.
STONE TEEN VOEPEL WALDRON WEBER.
WICKS WOOD MISTER SPEAKER
.
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS PRESENT.
A QUORUM IS PRESENT IN THE
ASSEMBLY.
WE ASK THAT OUR GUESTS AND
VISITORS IN THE REAR OF THE
CHAMBER AND IN THE GALLERY
PLEASE STAND FOR THE PRAYER.
TODAY'S PRAYER.
WILL BE OFFERED BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RADIUS ASSEMBLY MEMBER IS
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN PRAYER.
LORD WE COME BEFORE YOU SEEKING
YOUR BLESSING ON OUR HOUSE OUR
COMMUNITY AND OUR MEMBERS.
WE PRAY YOU REMIND US OF OUR
GIFTS AND RESPONSIBILITIES FROM
OUR DON TO OUR SUNSET.
WE OFTEN CELEBRATE THE BEGINNING
OF LIFE WITH GREAT ANTICIPATION
WE DREAM OF THE POSSIBILITIES OF
A FUTURE WITHOUT LIMITS AND
WITHOUT BORDERS.
AS THE YEARS PROGRESS WE FIND
THERE ARE LIMITS AND WE EACH
WORK TO PUSH BEYOND THOSE LIMITS
FOR SELVES AND FOR THOSE WHO
COME AFTER US.
SOME HAVE SEEN SEGREGATION AND
FOUGHT FOR INCLUSION.
SOME HAVE SEEN INJUSTICES AND
FOUGHT FOR EQUITY.
SOME HAVE FACED CLOSED DOORS
HIGH WALLS AND GLASS CEILINGS
AND FOUGHT TO BREAK THROUGH THEM.
FOR SOME IT HAS BEEN A VERY
PERSONAL BATTLE TO BETTER
THEMSELVES. FOR OTHERS THE PART
HAS BEEN FOR FUTURE GENERATIONS.
AS WE MOVE THROUGH THIS
LEGISLATIVE YEAR I PRAY THAT WE
COMMIT TO FIGHT FOR THOSE WHO DO
NOT HAVE THE SAME FUTURE.
THE SAME FUTURE OPPORTUNITIES
SIMPLE SIMPLY BECAUSE OF WHERE
THEY WERE BORN OR THE PARENTS
WHO BORE THEM.
WE ARE SMART ENOUGH.
WISE ENOUGH TO KNOW WHEN WE ARE
WITNESSING INJUSTICES.
WE KNOW WHEN SOMEONE IS
SUFFERING SIMPLY BECAUSE OF THE
COLOR OF THEIR SKIN.
THE LACK OF MONEY IN THEIR
POCKET.
THE GOD THEY BELIEVE IN THE
LANGUAGE THEY SPEAK OR THE
ABILITIES THE LIMITS OF THEIR
ABILITIES.
I PRAY THAT WE DO NOT LOOK AWAY.
I PRAY THAT WE USE OUR POSITION
OF THE RESPONSIBILITY THAT COMES
WITH IT TO GO BEYOND WORDS AND
RHETORIC.
I PRAY THAT WE LOOK FOR
SOLUTIONS TO TEACH AND PROTECT
OUR CHILDREN AND GIVE THEM A
SENSE OF BELONGING.
I PRAY THAT WE GIVE HONOR AND
RESPECT TO THOSE WHO HAVE
SACRIFICED FOR THE REST OF US.
I PRAY THAT WE LEAN ON EACH
OTHER AND TOGETHER LEAN IN TO
PUSH DOWN THE DOORS ON THE WALLS
THAT SERVES ONLY TO LIMIT THE
DREAMS AND HOPES.
OF THE VERY PEOPLE WE ARE CALLED
ON TO REPRESENT.
LESS LORD AND HELP US FIND THOSE
SOLUTIONS TOGETHER IN YOUR
PRECIOUS NAME.
AMEN.
THANK YOU MS RACE WE ASK OUR
GUESTS AND VISITORS TO REMAIN
STANDING AND JOIN US FOR THE
FLAG SALUTE PLEASE JOIN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BIGELOW.
AS HE LEADS US IN THE PLEDGE
MISTER BIGELOW WOULD YOU ALL
PLEASE JOIN ME IN SAYING I
PLEDGE.
I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG.
OF THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA
[inaudible] ZERO SAN. ONE
NATION.
INDIVISIBLE WITH LIBERTY AND
JUSTICE FOR ALL.
THANK YOU YOU MAY BE SEATED.
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL.
ASSEMBLY CHAMBER SACRAMENTO
WEDNESDAY JANUARY TWENTY THIRD
TWENTY NINETEEN THIS AND THEY
MET AT SEVEN AM ON WILL BRAND
DALY ASSEMBLY MEMBER FIRST
DISTRICT PRESIDING CHIEF PICKY
DOTSON WILSON AT THE DESK.
READING CLICK KATHLEEN AND LOUIS
READING THE FOLLOWING A PLACE ON
THE MORNING ROLL CALL AND WE ARE
CURRY ARAMBULA BOWS SHEARER.
GIPSON MOVES AND MISS WALDRON
SECONDS.
AT THE READING OF THE PREVIOUS
DAY'S JOURNAL BE DISPENSED WITH.
EXHORTATIONS HABITATIONS THERE
ARE NONE.
INTRODUCTION AND REFERENCE OF
BILLS WILL BE DEFERRED.
REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
DEEMED ADOPTED.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR THERE
ARE NONE.
MESSAGES FROM THE SENATE.
THERE ARE NONE.
WOULD YOU MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS.
ABSENCES FOR THE DAY. FOR
LEGISLATIVE BUSINESS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER HEATH FLORA FOR PERSONAL
BUSINESS ASSEMBLY MEMBER BRIAN
DALLY AND FOR ILLNESS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CALDERON
.
MEMBERS WE ARE A PROCEDURAL
MOTIONS MISTER BONTA YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR PROCEDURAL
MOTION SIR.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE ONE
EIGHTEEN A TO ALLOW
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WICKS. TO HAVE
GUESTS AND PHOTOGRAPHERS ON THE
FLOOR TODAY HER GUESTS WILL BE
SEATED AT HER DESK.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER.
HI FOR THE REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE
FORTY FIVE POINT FIVE AND ALLOW
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS EAGER SEE --
RAY AS GAP BRO COOLEY AND WEBER
TO SPEAK ON AN ADJOURNMENT IN
MEMORY TODAY.
AND AGAIN WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER.
MEMBERS WE HAVE SPECIAL GUEST
WITH US IN THE CHAMBER TODAY.
MEMBERS.
PLEASE GIVE YOUR ATTENTION AS
WICKS.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WHICH YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR V. I. P.
INTRODUCTION.
MY MY V. I. P. INTRODUCTION
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS --
UP PLEASE MEET MY DAUGHTER.
JOSEPHINE WE COLOR JOE JOE WHICH
EMPLOYER WHO IS HERE --
COLORING FOR YOU ALL --
WE'RE WITHOUT CHILD CARE TODAY
SO -- TO
WORK TODAY.
THANK YOU
AS WE HAVE ADDITIONAL
GAS IN THE CHAMBER TODAY
[inaudible]
MEMBERS.
PLEASE YOUR ATTENTION MISTER
COOPER MISS COOPER YOUR GAS.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER TODAY
IS MY PLEASURE TO INTRODUCE AND
RECOGNIZE THE EXECUTIVE TEAM OF
THE CALIFORNIA YOUTH FOOTBALL
ALLIANCE.
ALLIANCE IS COMMITTED TO
HONORING IMPROVING AND ADVANCING
THE SPORT OF YOUTH TACKLE
FOOTBALL THEY'RE TAKING MAJOR
STEPS TO KEEP OUR CHILDREN SAFE.
COLLEAGUES PLEASE JOIN ME IN
WELCOMING MISTER JOE RAFTER THE
PRESIDENT.
MITTERRAND WHITE EXECUTIVE VICE
PRESIDENT OF THE CALIFORNIA
YOUTH FOOTBALL ASSOCIATION TO
OUR STATE CAPITOL
.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO MOVE.
TO ASSEMBLY THIRD READING.
BUSINESS ON THE DAILY FILE
ASSEMBLY THIRD READING
.
CORRECTION MEMBERS WE ARE GOING
TO MOVE TO THE CONCURRENCE FILE
WE HAVE ONE ITEM ON CONCURRENCE.
THIS IS FILE ITEM NUMBER.
ONE AC ARE THREE BY.
DOCTOR CHOI CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
THREE BY SOME THE NUMBER CHOI
AND OTHERS RELATIVE TO CREATE
AMERICAN DAY.
DOCTOR CHOI EMAIL WITH.
THANK YOU SPEAKER AND THE GOOD
MORNING MEMBERS.
TODAY I PRESENT TO YOU A C. R.
THREE THE RECOGNIZING KOREAN
AMERICAN DAY THAT IS SO ON
CONCURRENCE.
NOR SUBSTANCE ON THE MAN ONE SO
WERE MADE TO A SITE --
TO ADDING COST US ARE IN THE
SENATE.
TO WHEN THIS MANAGER.
WITH THAT THAT I A RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR I'VE WORKED.
THANK YOU DOCTOR CHOI SAYING NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE ITEM.
CLICK WELL THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT ABOUT.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE [inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE A ROLL TIDE ABOUT AYE.
SIXTY EIGHT NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE COULD KERN IN.
AND NOW MEMBERS WE WILL MOVE TO
ASSEMBLY THIRD READING.
JUST ONE ITEM TODAY THIS IS FILE
ITEM NUMBER.
TWO HR TWELVE THE CLERK WILL
READ HOUSE RESOLUTION TWELVE BY
SOME A MEMBER GIPSON AND OTHERS
RELATIVE TO BLACK HIV AIDS
AWARENESS DAY.
MISTER GIBSON YOU MAY OPEN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS.
ARE [inaudible]
MEMBERS.
YOUR ATTENTION AS YOU GIPSON
PLEASE.
I RISE AS A PROUD AUTHOR.
OF HR TWELVE WHICH WILL CLAIMS
TODAY.
AS BLACK HIV AWARENESS DAY IN
CALIFORNIA.
TODAY MORE THAN ONE POINT TWO
MILLION PEOPLE LIVING IN THE
UNITED STATES ARE AFFECTED WITH
HIV.
AND ONE IN EIGHT ARE UNAWARE OF
THEIR INFECTIOUS RATE.
ALTHOUGH HIV AND AIDS IMPACT
EVERY COMMUNITY.
EVERY COMMUNITY THE BLACK
COMMUNITY HAS BEEN IMPACTED
EXPRESSLY.
AND HIT HARD BY THIS DISEASE THE
BLACK COMMUNITY MAKE UP 13% OF
THE U. S. POPULAR POPULATION BUT
ACCOUNTS 4403% OF THE NEW.
HIV DIAGNOSIS A NUMBER OF
CHALLENGES CONTRIBUTE TO THIS
EPIDEMIC IN MY COMMUNITY.
THIS INCLUDES HIGH POVERTY.
LACK OF ACCESS TO HEALTHCARE.
LACK.
OF AWARENESS OF HIV STATUS
EGGMAN ASSOCIATED WITH THIS
DISEASE AS THE CHAIR OF THE
PICTURE DISEASES IN HIGH RISK
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES.
I AM COMMITTED TO RAISING
AWARENESS AND WORKING ON
LEGISLATION THAT WILL ADDRESS
THIS CRISIS.
AND AS A POINT OF SPECIAL
PRIVILEGE.
I NEVER WANTED TO BE IN THIS
SPACE [inaudible]
SUCH.
I NEVER WANTED TO BE IN THIS
SPACE. TWO INDIVIDUALS THAT I
LOVE VERY VERY MUCH WERE
EXTENDED MEMBERS OF MY FAMILY.
SHANIA ROD.
SHANER ROD BROUGHT.
A VIVACIOUS BABY BORN INTO THIS
WORLD.
AND AT SIX YEARS OLD.
LITTLE ROCK LOST HIS FATHER.
DO TO COMPLICATIONS OF AIDS.
AND THEN SHORTLY THERE AFTER SIX
MONTHS OR SO LOST HIS MOTHER.
AT SIX YEARS OLD LOSING BOTH
PARENTS. TO AIDS.
SO WHAT THIS SPACE.
EVEN THOSE UNCOMFORTABLE BUT
IT'S SOMETHING THAT I FIND
MYSELF FIGHTING FOR EACH AND
EVERY DAY TO MAKING SURE THAT NO
OF THE FAMILY NO ONE IN
CALIFORNIA HAS TO DIE
[inaudible]
WITH AIDS.
SO THAT'S THE REASON WHY FIGHT
AND I WILL CONTINUE TO FIGHT IN
THIS SPACE.
UNTIL THERE'S NO MORE REASON TO
FIGHT.
THE THEME FOR THIS RESOLUTION.
STAY THE COURSE THE FIGHT IS NOT
OVER.
SO I URGE.
THAT WE COME TOGETHER TO STAY
THE COURSE.
AND WE FIGHT TO GETTING TO ZERO
NEW INFECTIOUS CASES IN
CALIFORNIA.
MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY ASK WHEN
I VOTE ON HR. TWELVE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER GIBSON.
DR WEBER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS.
AYE TO RISE IN SUPPORT OF HR
TWELVE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE BLACK
CAUCUS.
WE IN TOTAL SUPPORT OF RAISING
THE ISSUE AND MAKING IT A MAJOR
CONCERN.
YOU A NINETEEN EIGHTY NINE ONE
OF MY BEST FRIENDS DIED.
HE WAS A YOUNG MAN WHO I'VE
HEARD SAN DIEGO STATE ONE OF THE
MOST VIVACIOUS INDIVIDUAL YOU
WOULD KNOW AND SOME OF YOU WHO
TENANTS AND EAGLES DON'T KNOW DR
DANI SCARBOROUGH.
IT WAS AT THE HEIGHT OF THE AIDS.
EPIDEMIC.
AND HE WAS.
ASHAMED EMBARRASSED.
TRIED NOT TO LET FOLKS KNOW WE
HAD IT BUT IN THE END DANNY WAS
A GODPARENT. TO MY KIDS PASSED
AWAY.
AND TO THIS DAY WE STILL
REMEMBER DANNY AND THE AND THE
ENERGY HE HAD IN HIS ABILITY TO
TRANSFORM CLASSROOMS AND EVENTS
INTO A MAJOR THINGS HE'D HAVE
YOUNG FOOTBALL PLAYERS WALKING
DOWN THE HALL.
QUOTING OR FELLOW.
AND BECAUSE HE WAS SUCH A
DYNAMIC INSTRUCTIONS AND WE MISS
HIM IMMENSELY.
SO IN.
TWO THOUSAND THREE I TRAVEL TO
MY FIRST TRIP TO SOUTH AFRICA.
AND IT WAS THE WORK WITH LOVE
LIFE WHICH WAS AN AIDS PROJECT.
AND I HAD A CHANCE TO GO TO THE
VILLAGES AND TO SEE WHAT WAS
HAPPENING AT THE HEIGHT OF THE
AIDS PROJECT AIDS EPIDEMIC.
AND I SAW HOW COMMUNITIES ARE
GRAPPLING WITH THIS WHOLE ISSUE
WITH MORE MYTHS AND FACTS.
AND WILL BE LEAVING THAT IF THEY
HAVE SEX WITH A VIRGIN THEY
WOULD GET RID OF AIDS AND SO WE
HAVE THE RAPING OF A LOT OF
CHILDREN.
AND EVEN THE RAPING OF NEWBORNS.
FORTUNATELY FOR US THIS
GOVERNMENT STARTED PEPFAR IN
SOUTH AFRICA.
UNDER GEORGE BUSH.
AND IN AT THREE TO FOUR YEAR
PERIOD ME GOING TO SOUTH AFRICA
EVERY YEAR WORKING ON VARIOUS
PROJECTS.
WE SAW DRAMATIC CHANGE AND A
TURN AROUND THAT WAS AMAZING IN
SOUTH AFRICA.
IN TERMS OF STOPPING THE
INFECTIONS SAVING LIVES
PREVENTING THE TRANSFERENCE OF
TO THE DISEASE TO THE INFANTS
BECAUSE OF LEARNING HOW TO
DELIVER BABIES IN DIFFERENT WAYS.
AND SO AS A RESULT WE SAW WHAT
THE UNITED STATES CAN DO.
WHEN HE PUTS HIS FOCUS ON?
WE SAW WHAT IT'S DONE WHEN WHEN
MAGIC JOHNSON TO ANNOUNCE THAT
HE HAD AIDS.
HOW THE FOCUS OF OF RESEARCH AND
MEDICAL CARE AND EVERYTHING
FOCUS SO THE NOW AS A SOCIETY?
WE DON'T LIVE UNDER THE SHADOW
OF AIDS AND SOME OF YOU OLD
ENOUGH TO REMEMBER HOW HORRIBLE
IT WAS WHAT I FEARED WAS BECAUSE
IT TRULY WAS A DEFINITE
STATEMENT THAT YOU GOT IT.
WHAT THIS SAYS TO ME VERY
CLEARLY THAT WOULD WANT ADMIN
SAID ABOUT EDUCATION?
THAT WE KNOW EVERYTHING WE NEED
TO KNOW A OBJECT.
WHAT WE LACK IS THE WILL?
WE LACK THE WILL.
AND IT IS SHAMEFUL THAT IN THIS
COUNTRY AT THIS TIME.
AFRICAN AMERICAN MEN AND WOMEN.
ARE STILL BEING DIAGNOSED AT A
HIGHER RATE THAN ANY OTHER GROUP.
AND IT HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH DO
WE HAVE THE MONEY IT HAS NOTHING
TO DO WOULD DO WE HAVE THE
KNOWLEDGE.
DO WE HAVE THE CARE WILL BE
SHOULD HAVE THE PASSION AND
COULD AND CARE.
FOR BUT IT LACKS THE WILL.
AND MANY OF THESE FOLKS ARE
SHAMED THEY REMIND ME OF WHAT I
WOULD TO GOD TO TAKE MONEY. TO
AN AIDS PROJECT I HAD TO MEET
THEM IN A BACK ROOM AT AT THE
PEACE CORPS BECAUSE THEY DIDN'T
WANT ANYBODY TO SEE THEM GETTING
THIS MONEY.
BECAUSE THEY THEY WERE SO
ASHAMED IN THE VILLAGES THEY
KNEW THAT IF SOMEBODY TO THEY
HAD AIDS TO BE OSTRACIZED.
THAT STILL EXISTS TODAY IN
AFRICAN AMERICAN COMMUNITIES
ACROSS THE NATION.
WE HAVE TO PUT A FOCUS ON THIS.
THIS IS AN IMPORTANT ISSUE I
WANT TO THANK MY COLLEAGUE FOR
BRINGING IT FORWARD BECAUSE
WHILE WE CAN CELEBRATE THE
WONDERS OF MEDICINE AND WHAT WE
CAN DO ALL AROUND THE WORLD
WHERE THIS DEALING WITH AIDS.
OR ANY OTHER KIND OF DISEASE TO
FOCUS ON THOSE WHO LIVE HERE.
WHO IS STILL UNDER THE SHADOW
WHO ARE DYING AT ALARMING RATES
WHO TRANSFERRING THE DISEASE TO
OTHERS AND WHO LIVE IN THE
SHADOW OF SHAME?
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOU I
VOTE FOR THIS RESOLUTION AND
THAT IT IMPACTS OUR BUDGET.
AND OUR POLICIES IN THE STATE.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU DOCTOR WEBER MISTER
GLORIA.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER --
TRY TO MAKE IT HAPPEN NOT A
FOLLOWING MY COLLEAGUE FROM SAN
DIEGO HER COMMENTS ARE STERN
PROFOUND IT'S DIFFICULT TO ADD
TO THEM.
ARE I SIMPLY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA.
LEGISLATIVE LGBT CAUCUS IN
SOLIDARITY WITH THE CALIFORNIA
BLACK LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS AND MY
COLLEAGUE FROM CARSON A JUST SET
SIGNAL OUR SUPPORT FOR THIS
RESOLUTION.
IN I RECOGNIZE THAT THESE
RESOLUTION SOMETIMES FEEL --
BUT THEY'RE NOT THEY DON'T DO A
LOT.
BUT I THINK THAT --
MY COLLEAGUE FROM SAN DIEGO'S
COMMENTS RECOGNIZING WHAT HER
FRIEND FELT FELT AND DOT WITH --
OVER TWENTY YEARS AGO SADLY
STILL VERY MUCH THE CASE TODAY.
AND SO WHAT MAY SEEM.
UNNECESSARY TO TALK ABOUT THIS
ISSUE WE KNOW --
THAT THE AFRICAN AMERICAN HE
LIVES IN THE INTERSECTIONS OF A
LOT OF A DESPERATE TREATMENT.
AND WHETHER IT'S RACIAL OR
ECONOMIC A GENDER ORIENTATION
THIS COMMUNITY IS
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED BY
HIV AND SIMILE IS
DISPROPORTIONATELY NOT IMPACTED
BY THE END INNOVATIONS AND
IMPROVEMENTS OF CON.
OBVIOUSLY I KNOW A LOT OF FOLKS
WHO HAVE DEALT WITH THIS DISEASE.
FOLKS WHO'D NOW OUR LIVING OF
QUITE HEALTHFULLY OTHER FOLKS
THAT ARE PROTECTED BECAUSE THE
RESEARCH THAT QUITE FRANKLY
COMES OUT OF MY ASSEMBLY
DISTRICT --
THE WORLD THE NEW DATE IT'S A
NEW WORLD WHEN IT COMES HIV
INFECTIONS AND YET THAT HAS NOT
PENETRATED EVERY COMMUNITY AND
WE LOOK AT NEW INFECTION RATES
ACROSS THIS COUNTRY WE
UNDERSTAND IT SEE THEM FALLING
IN CERTAIN COMMUNITIES.
AND YET CONTINUE PERSISTENTLY
HIGH IN OTHER IN THE AFRICAN
AMERICAN COMMUNITY IS ALSO TRUE
IN THE LATINO COMMUNITY AND
COURSE NOW JUDY COMMUNITY THIS
CONTINUES TO BE A FUN OF MY
CONCERN.
SO OF MEMBERS EITHER THIS
RESOLUTION DOES HAVE POWER
BECAUSE WE HAVE A SITUATION
WHERE PEOPLE STILL STAND IN
SILENCE AND ARE NOT INFORMED OF
MEDICATIONS THAT ARE AVAILABLE
THE COULD PREVENT INFECTIONS.
MEDICATIONS THAT COULD EXTEND
AND IMPROVE THE QUALITY OF LIFE
WHEN WE KNOW THAT FOLKS WILL NOT
STEP OUT OF THE CLOSET BECAUSE
IT'S TOO HARD IN THAT MAY
ACTUALLY CAN SIGN INTO A
SITUATION WHERE THEY EVEN HIGHLY
MORE VULNERABLE TO IN HIV
INFECTION.
THEN WE MUST VOTE WE MUST BRING
UP THIS RESOLUTION WE MUST TALK
ABOUT THIS BECAUSE THESE WORDS
ARE AND FACT POWERFUL AND THEY
PENETRATE INTO OUR COMMUNITIES
AND THEY MAY PREVENT AN
INFECTION THEY MAY GET SOMEONE
TO GET INTO.
CARE AND PREVENT THEIR ABILITY
TO SPREAD THE DISEASE IT MAY
ACTUALLY BE ABLE TO SAVE A LIFE
SO I THINK THIS IS VERY POWERFUL
I THINK THIS IS VERY IMPORTANT I
THINK MY COLLEAGUE FROM CARSON.
BUT NOT TO SHARE HIS PERSONAL
EXPERIENCES BEFORE BRINGING THIS
RESOLUTION BEFORE US.
WE HAVE COME A LONG WAY BEFORE
TOO MANY COMMUNITIES IN A
PARTICULAR IN THE AFRICAN
AMERICAN UNITY WE HAVE STILL SO
MUCH FURTHER TO GO SO AGAIN ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE LGBT CAUCUS WE STAND
AGAIN IN STRONG SOLIDARITY.
WITH OUR WITH THE BLACK CAUCUS
AND WITH OF MY COLLEAGUE FROM
CARSON AND ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT
TO SPEAK OUT AND GIVE VOICE TO
PEOPLE WHO'VE OFTEN FEEL
VOICELESS. TO OPEN THE DOORS TO
DISCUSSIONS THAT ARE ALL TOO
OFTEN CLOSE INTO IMPORTANTLY TO
FINALLY BE A COMMUNITY THAT WILL
END THE SPREAD OF HIV.
IT IS MEDICALLY IN TECHNICALLY
POSSIBLE WE JUST MUST HAVE THE
WILL TO DO IT I HOPE THEY WILL
ALL HOLD OURSELVES ACCOUNTABLE
IN THE WEEKS AND MONTHS AHEAD TO
SUPPORT LEGISLATION THAT WOULD
DO EXACTLY THAT.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
THANK YOU MISS GLORIA.
SEEING NO OTHER MEMBERS SEEKING
RECOGNITION ON THE RESOLUTION.
MR GIVES YOU MAY CLOSE IF YOU
WISH.
THIS GIVES WOULD YOU LIKE CO
AUTHORS ON THE FIRST ROLL.
MEMBERS THE ROLE WILL BE OPEN
FOR CO AUTHORS ON HR TWELVE
PURPLE OF THE ROLE.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
CO AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION.
MEMBERS THIS IS CO AUTHORS
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL THEIR SEVENTY SEVEN
CO AUTHORS ADDED TO THE
RESOLUTION AND WITHOUT OBJECTION
WE MAY TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THE
RESOLUTION ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SAY AYE.
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE AYES HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION.
IS ADOPTED.
MEMBERS WE HAVE SPECIAL GAS.
WHO ARRIVES IN THE CHAMBER?
DOCTOR CHAN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FOR YOUR GUESTS INTRODUCTION.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER IN
HONOR --
FITNESS WEEK THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA MY COLLEAGUE A KNIFE
FROM COURSE IN CALIFORNIA ONCE A
WELCOME TO AMAZING GUESTS WERE
LEADERS IN THE FITNESS INDUSTRY.
ONE IS MARK BELL WHO HAS BEEN
HERE A HOME SON IN WEST
SACRAMENTO --
THE CEO FOUNDER SLING SHOT
CHAMPION POWER LIFTER AND BODY
BUILDER AND WE HAVE THE AMAZING
BROKE ADDS ACROSS THE CHAMPION
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
BUT ALSO A FITNESS ADVOCATE IN A
WORLDWIDE INFLUENCE ARE IN THE
WORLD OF WELL BEING ALSO A STAR
OF WONDER WOMAN.
WITH THAT WE WANT TO WALKING
TICU THE STATE ASSEMBLY MARK
BELL AND PROJECTS PLEASE GIVE A
WARM WELCOME MY FRIENDS
[inaudible]
IN.
MR GIVE SAN I NEGLECTED TO
RETURN TO YOUR FOR YOUR GAS
INTRODUCTION RELATIVE TO THE
RESOLUTION THAT WAS JUST ADOPTED
BY THIS HOUSE.
MISTER GIBSON FOR YOUR SPECIAL
GUEST INTRODUCTION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER GIVES ME GREAT.
THEY CAN PLEASE RISE --
SOME VISITORS SOME GUEST OUR
HOUSE OF FIRST WANT TO START BY.
ACKNOWLEDGING REINA COPELAND THE
PRESIDENT CEO OF THE BLACK AIDS
INSTITUTE NEXT ALEXIS DALY
HEALTH EDUCATOR S. T. I. TESTING
COORDINATOR WITH THE SACRAMENTO
LGBT.
I'M COMMUNITY CENTER TONY
BRADFORD --
ASSOCIATE DIRECTOR OF COMMUNITY
ENGAGEMENT WITH THE SAN
FRANCISCO AIDS FOUNDATION AND
MISTER RIC HARRIS --
LEGISLATIVE ADVOCATE FOR THE IN
DOUBLE ACP THERE IN THIS FIGHT
WITH ME.
MEMBERS PLEASE PUT YOUR HANDS
TOGETHER AND WELCOME OUR GUESTS
.
AND MEMBERS WE HAVE. ONE
REMAINING GUEST INTRODUCTION
DOCTOR WHERE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FOR YOUR GUESTS INTRODUCTION
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I'D LIKE YOU TO ASK YOU
TO JOIN ME IN WELCOMING THE
HONORABLE SENATOR JUAN MANUEL
GALAN ACCIONES.
OF COLUMBIA HE'S OR ANYTHING
HERE IN THE GALLERY TODAY WITH
THE STAFF HE IS HERE TO LEARN
FROM CALIFORNIA POLICY MAKERS ON
THE REGULATE OUR REGULATORY
SYSTEM FOR MEDICAL AND
RECREATIONAL CANNABIS.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN WELCOMING
SENATOR GALL.
MEMBERS WE HAVE A CONSENT
CALENDAR TODAY.
THIS.
IS A MEMBER WISH TO REMOVE AN
ITEM FROM THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
SEEING HEARING ON THE CLERK WILL
READ THE SECOND A CONSENT
CALENDAR.
AT SOME LEVEL ONE FORTY NINE BY
SOMETHING MEMBER COOPER AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY TO
CONTROLLED SUBSTANCES DECLARING
THE URGENCY THERE UP TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE WRONG
CALENDAR ALL MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE THIS IS THE
CONSENT CALENDAR MEMBERS ALL
MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE?
AND THE CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ROLE.
AND TALLY THE VOTE.
I IS SEVENTY FIVE KNOW ZERO ON
THE URGENCY.
I SEVENTY FIVE NO.
ZERO ON THE MEASURE THE CONSENT
CALENDAR IS ADOPTED.
MEMBERS MOVING TO ANNOUNCEMENTS.
THE GOVERNOR WILL BE DELIVERING
HIS STATE OF THE STATE ADDRESS
NEXT TUESDAY FEBRUARY TWELFTH.
FLOOR SESSION WILL CONVENE AT
TEN THIRTY AM THE JOINT
CONVENTION WILL CONVENE AT TEN
FORTY FIVE AM.
AND THEN THE GOVERNOR WILL
DELIVER HIS SPEECH AT ELEVEN AM.
SESSION SCHEDULE IS AS FOLLOWS
FRIDAY FEBRUARY NO FLOOR SESSION
AT NO CHECK IN SESSION MONDAY.
FEBRUARY ELEVENTH THE FLOOR
SESSION IS AT ONE PM.
WITHOUT OBJECTION THE QUORUM
CALL IS LIFTED.
AND WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
PREVIOUSLY ANNOUNCED
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY.
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS
OR TAKE YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF
OF THE GREEN CARPET
.
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR
CONVERSATIONS OFF OF THE FLOOR.
THE FOLLOWING MEMBERS WERE
GRANTED PRIOR PERMISSION TO
SPEAK ON ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY
[inaudible]
MR [inaudible]
EDUARDO GARCIA.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
TODAY TO ADJOURN THE MEMORY OF
WILLIS HUDDLESTON WHO PASSED
AWAY.
ON DECEMBER TWENTY FOURTH.
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN WILLIS
BEGAN HIS CAREER WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF WATER RESOURCES IN
NINETEEN SIXTY WHICH THEN HE
RETIRED.
FROM THE DEPARTMENT IN. NINETEEN
NINETY SEVEN ONE THE STORIES IT
WILL IS SO OFTEN TOLD.
AND WAS VERY PROUD OF WAS THAT
IN.
NINETEEN SEVENTY TWO HE FORMED A
STRIKE.
STRATEGY COMMITTEE WHERE HE LED
THE FIRST AND ONLY SUCCESSFUL
STRIKE AGAINST THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
OBTAINING A 35% PAY INCREASE
OVER THREE YEARS FOR WORKERS OF
THE DEPARTMENT OF WATER
RESOURCES.
OVER A TEN YEAR PERIOD BEGINNING
IN NINETEEN EIGHTY HE MADE
AGREEMENT WITH THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY FIRE DEPARTMENT FOR THE
USE OF INMATE LABOR TO DO
GENERAL CLEAN UP.
AND WE CONTROL ALONG THE ATTIC I
COULD NOT.
THIS AGREEMENT SAVE THE STATE
THREE HUNDRED AND THIRTY MILLION
DOLLARS DURING THAT TIME FRAME.
HE SERVED AS PRESIDENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE EMPLOYEES
ASSOCIATION CHAPTER ONE EIGHTY
SEVEN FOR FIVE YEARS.
WAS ASKED TO FORM THE CALIFORNIA
STATE SUPERVISOR CHAPTER.
NINETEEN SEVENTY EIGHT THEN
SERVED AS PRESIDENT.
OF THAT CHAPTER UNTIL RETIREMENT
IN.
NINETEEN NINETY SEVEN AFTER
RETIREMENT IN TRAVELING IN A
MOTOR HOME FOR SEVEN AND A HALF
YEARS WILL LISTEN HIS WIFE MOVED
TO THE UNINCORPORATED RIVERSIDE
COUNTY COMMUNITY.
OF DESERT AGE WITHIN THE
COACHELLA VALLEY FIVE MONTHS
DOWN IN LOUISIANA AFTER
HURRICANE KATRINA WAS CAME BACK
TO THE COACHELLA VALLEY AND
BECAME VERY INTERESTED IN
EMERGENCY PREPAREDNESS.
AND FORM THE COMMUNITY EMERGENCY
RESPONSE TEAM.
IN CALIENTE SPRINGS RESORT I
WANT TO SHARE WITH YOU THAT
WILLIS AND HIS WIFE --
SINCE TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN
VOLUNTEERED IN OUR OFFICE AS
COMMUNITY AMBASSADORS.
REPRESENTING US IN A VARIETY OF
EVENTS AND ACTIVITIES THROUGHOUT
OUR DISTRICT GUY HE'S GOING TO
BE.
VERY MUCH MISSED AND WE WANT TO
ADJOURN IN HIS MEMORY --
THIS AFTERNOON THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MR GARCIA.
ASSEMBLY WOMAN RAY S.. FOR YOUR
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS.
TODAY I RISE.
ALSO WE JOURNEY THE MEMORY OF A
LEADER IN OUR COMMUNITY WHO
DEDICATED HIS ENTIRE LIFE FOR
THE BENEFIT OF ALL.
FATHER BUT THREE CO GET YEN ALSO
KNOWN AS FATHER PAT WAS A PRIEST
FOR OVER SIXTY YEARS.
HE WAS MY FRIEND.
IS VERY PROUD OF THE WORK THAT I
HAD DONE AND OFTEN WHEN I WOULD
COME TO VISIT HIM ON WEEKENDS.
HE WOULD SAY THE BILL BE THERE'S
A PUEBLO DO NOT FORGET TO DON'T
DO NOT FORGET THE PEOPLE.
HE WAS A FRIEND TO THE COMMUNITY
THAT FOUND ITSELF MARGINALIZED
DISCRIMINATED AGAINST.
AND LEFT BEHIND.
IN THE OPENING PRAYER I PRAYED
THAT WE WOULDN'T TURN AWAY WHEN
WE WITNESSED INJUSTICES.
I PRAY THAT WE WOULD FIGHT FOR
INCLUSION AND EQUITY.
FATHER PAT DID JUST THAT HE
FOUND EVERY OPPORTUNITY TO
UPLIFT THE DOWNTRODDEN THE
DISTRESSED IN THE HOPELESS.
HIS LIFE WOULD BE MEASURED BY
HIS ACTIONS NOT JUST HIS WORDS.
FATHER GIDEON TALKED THROUGH NOT
ONLY HIS ROLE IN THE CHURCH.
BUT THROUGH HIS ROLE AS AN
ACTIVIST IN THE COMMUNITY.
AS A CHILD OF MY GRANDPARENTS
FATHER GIDEON WAS ACTIVE ON
SOCIAL JUSTICE ISSUES HELPING
ESTABLISH LEE BUT THE OTHER WAY
BELOW A NONPROFIT SANDRA DINO
AGENCY THAT SERVES THE LATINO
IMMIGRANTS COMMUNITY.
HIS PRESENCE IN THE INLAND
EMPIRE WILL NEVER BE FORGOTTEN
HE WAS A MENTOR TO MANY A
CONFIDANTE SPIRITUAL ADVISER
FIGHTER WAR YEAR.
I GET ADAM FOR THE PEOPLE'S
RIGHTS.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK THE WE
ADJOURNED IN MEMORY OF FATHER
BUT THE PEACE YOGI ON THANK YOU
MS REYES.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER DEEP.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
GERMAN MEMORY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MISTER
SPEAKER I RISE TODAY --
TO ASKED THAT WE ADJOURN THE
SESSION IN MEMORY OF THE LATE
CHIEF TOM TOLES.
OF THE GARDEN GROVE FIVE
DEPARTMENT CHIEF BILLS PASSED
AWAY ON JANUARY TWENTY SEVENTH.
JUST WEEKS AFTER HE WAS
DIAGNOSED PANCREATIC AND LIVER
CANCER.
CHIEF SO JOIN THE GARDEN GROVE
FIVE DEPARTMENT ON APRIL TWENTY
NINTH.
TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN AS THE
THIRTEENTH FIRE CHIEF.
HE STARTED HIS PUBLIC SERVICE
CAREER IN NINETEEN EIGHTY FIVE
AT THE FULTON FIRE DEPARTMENT
WHERE HE REACHED THE RANK OF
DEPUTY CHIEF OF OPERATION.
DURING THAT TIME HE WAS
INSTRUMENTAL IN ESTABLISHING THE
CONSOLIDATED COMMAND STAFF TO
MANAGE BOTH.
THE FULTON AND BREYER FIRE
DEPARTMENTS HE HELD LEADERSHIP
POSITIONS IN ORGANIZATIONS SUCH
AS THE ORANGE COUNTY FIRE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATIONS.
AND MANY COUNTY AND STATE
COMMITTEES STROKES TRAINING
HUNDRED OF PEOPLE AT THE SANTA
ANA COLLEGE FAR TECHNOLOGY
PROGRAM.
WHAT HE TAUGHT FOR THE PAST
TWENTY FIVE YEARS?
GARDEN GROVE MAYOR STEVE JONES
SAID IT BEST IN REGARDS TO HIS
FORMER CHIEF.
GARDEN GIRL HAS LOST AN
ADMIRABLE MAN AN EXCEPTIONAL
LEADER WHO PROBABLY DEVOTED
HIMSELF. TO PROTECTING LIVES AND
SERVING A COMMUNITY THAT WILL
FOREVER BE IN HIS THAT.
HE IS SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE KIM.
TWO DAUGHTERS SERRA MELISSA AND
HIS SON ANDREW.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT WE
ADJOURN IN HIS MEMORY THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER.
THANK YOU MISTY.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BRO.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
I ASSET THE OBJECT OF THE
ASSEMBLY INJURED IN THE MEMORY
OF ARTHUR RICHARD HASSLE BREAK.
OUR PASSED AWAY LAST WEDNESDAY
JANUARY THIRTIETH AT THE YOUNG
AGE OF NINETY TWO ART WAS --
ACTUALLY THE SEVENTY THIRD
DISTRICT.
ASSEMBLY --
VETERAN OF THE YEAR IN.
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN ART WAS
BORN IN CHICAGO BORN AS A
PATRIOT AND FERVENT LOVE FOR HIS
COUNTRY.
HE LISTED THE UNITED STATES NAVY
AND SERVED IN THE PACIFIC
THEATER FROM. 1-940-321-9406 AS
A NAVY SEABEE.
SERVED IN A HUNDRED FIFTH US
NAVAL CONSTRUCTION BATTALION.
IN NEW GUINEA HE SERVED IN THE
PHILIPPINES HE SERVED ON EVEN
JIMA AND OKINAWA.
AND THE TRUCK ISLAND UNTIL THE
END OF THE WAR FOLLOWING WORLD
WAR TWO ART REMAINED IN THE
UNITED STATES NAVY AS A
RESERVIST.
HE ATTENDED NORTHWESTERN
UNIVERSITY GRADUATED WITH A
DEGREE IN CIVIL ENGINEERING.
IN NINETEEN FORTY NINE ART WAS
RECALLED TO THE KOREAN WAR.
AS A NEWLY COMMISSIONED ENSIGN
ART WAS MOBILIZED IN
CONSTRUCTION BATTALION.
TO HIS TOUR TOOK HIM TO THE AT
CGG KIMBO ONE TWENTY FIVE AIR
BASE.
AND SERVED AT THE FROZEN CHOSEN
RESERVOIR.
IN NINETEEN FIFTY TWO HE WAS
HONORABLY DISCHARGED FROM THE
UNITED STATES NAVY.
AFTER SERVING IN THE MILITARY
JOIN THE LOS ANGELES POLICE
DEPARTMENT NAY SERVED THE
CITIZENS OF LA FROM.
NINETEEN FIFTY TWO TO NINETEEN
SIXTY AND THEN IN NINETEEN SIXTY
WANT TO START IS OWN
CONSTRUCTION COMPANY.
HE WAS VERY INVOLVED IN THE
COMMUNITY OF SAN JUAN CAPISTRANO --
HE STARTED AN ORGANIZATION --
HE SERVED IN THE VETERANS OF
FOREIGN WARS HE SERVED THE
ORANGE COUNTY NAVY LEAGUE --
THE SAN JUAN CAPISTRANO AMERICAN
LEGION POST.
SEVEN TWENTY ONE THE MARINE
CORPS LEAGUE OF SOUTH ORANGE
COUNTY SANTA MANY ELKS AND WAS
ON THE BOARD OF THE SALVATION
ARMY.
ARE ALSO --
BORN IN CHICAGO WAS A BIG CUBS
FAN.
AND ACTUALLY AFTER WORLD WAR TWO
WAS ABLE TO LIVE OUT HIS DREAM
TO BE PLAYED IN THE CUBS MINOR
LEAGUE SYSTEM FOR A FEW YEARS AS
A FIRST BASEMAN --
AS I SAID WE RECOGNIZE ART AS A
SEVENTY THIRD ASSEMBLY DISTRICT
BETTER IN THE YEAR.
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN AND IT'S
WITH SADNESS THAT I ASKED THAT
WE GERMANS MEMBER TODAY THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
THANK YOU MISTER BRO.
MR COOLEY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR GERMAN A MEMORY.
COLLEAGUES TODAY I RISE IN HONOR
OF ALICE LYTLE A CONSTITUENT OF
MINE HERE IN SACRAMENTO COUNTY --
AND I JUST WANT TO SAY IT IS A
TREMENDOUS HONOR TO REFLECT UPON
HER LIFE WITH YOU TODAY
[inaudible]
ON YOU'RE GONNA HEAR MORE ABOUT
HER LIFE IN A MOMENT BUT SHE WAS
APPOINTED.
A JURIST IN CALIFORNIA IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY THREE BY JERRY
BROWN.
JERRY BROWN WHO WHO LOVES HIS
LATIN.
AND I WANT TO SHARE WITH YOU A
LATIN EXPRESSION [inaudible]
LOCKS MENTORS [inaudible]
LOCKS ORBUS.
AND I WILL SAY THIS PHRASE.
RELATES TO ALICE LIDDELL'S LIFE
IN A VERY DIRECT WAY.
THE OPPORTUNITY SHE ENCOUNTERED.
RELEASED THE WHOLE PURPOSE OF
OUR LIFE.
LOOKS MANTIS LUXOR BREAST MEANS
LIGHT OF THE MIND.
LIGHT OF THE WORLD.
IS A REMINDER THAT IDEAS.
ARE THE THING WHICH CHANGE LIVES.
CHANGE HUMAN LIFE.
AND WHEN YOU LOOK AT ALICE LYTLE.
LIFE [inaudible]
YOU SEE.
THE CONSEQUENCE OF IDEAS
[inaudible]
THAT.
OUR IMPACTFUL ACROSS CENTURIES.
EVEN TODAY ARE ENJOYED HAVING
LITTLE JOE JOE --
WICKS ON THE FLOOR WITH US.
ALICE LIABLE AS A JURIST IN
SACRAMENTO COUNTY WITH VERY LONG
CALLS WITH JURORS TO FRIEND OF
MINE.
OPEN LOCK CASITA. TO PROVIDE A
SHELTER FOR PARENTS WERE GOING
TO BE IN COURT TO BRING THEIR
CHILDREN.
AND TO BE CARED FOR WHEN OTHER
PROCEEDINGS WERE GOING ON WHICH
IS ITSELF A NOTABLE IDEA.
THAT YOU WOULD WELCOME CHILDREN
IN THE SEAT OF GOVERNMENT AND
PROVIDE FOR THEM.
ARM BUT ARE MUCH LARGER WAY
LOCKS MENTIS LUXOR WRIST PLAYS
OUT.
I WILL TELL YOU.
ALICE LYELL'S PERRANCE SHE WAS
THE EIGHT CHILD OF TEN WERE FROM
THE SOUTH.
WHEN SHE WAS BORN SHE WAS IN NEW
IN NEWARK NEW JERSEY?
HER FAMILY HAD LEFT THE SOUTH.
AND MOVED TO NEW YORK CITY. TO
AVAIL THEMSELVES OF FREE PUBLIC
pPROSPECTS FOR THEIR CHILDREN.
WHICH IS A CONVERSATION AS FRESH.
AS OUR CURRENT NEW SESSION WE
HAVE A GOVERNOR TALKING ABOUT
IMPROVING ACCESS TO EDUCATION.
SO NOW SLIDE WE SEE SOMEONE'S
LIFE WAS TOUCH.
WHY ACCESS TO EDUCATION?
WHICH WAS PROVIDED BY POLICY
MAKERS.
THAT IDEA IN IMPROVING EDUCATION
IS NOT AMERICAN ID IT STARTED IN
FRANCE.
IN FRANCE THE FRENCH ESTABLISHED
LIKE COALS NORMAL LIKE COAL
SUPER YOUR THESE WERE TEACHER
TRAINING COLLEGES.
THIS IDEA CAME TO THIS COUNTRY
FIRST IN MASSACHUSETTS THE CITY
UNIVERSITY OF NEW YORK A STEP SE
LE COAL NOR MALL OR NORMAL
UNIVERSITY. TO TRAIN WOMEN. FOR
TEACHING.
AND IN AN ERA WHEN.
SCHOOLS PLAYED FAVORITES BASED
UPON RACE AND RELIGION AND THOSE
SORTS OF THINGS.
ALTHOUGH AS MANY DECADES SERVICE
SHE BEGAN SCHOOL WHAT BECAME THE
HUNTER COLLEGE.
HER SCHOOL FROM ITS FOUNDING.
HAD THIS VERY POWERFUL IDEA.
THAT ANY QUALIFIED WOMAN WAS
ELIGIBLE TO BE THEIR
IRRESPECTIVE OF RACE RELIGION.
ECONOMICS [inaudible]
ARM.
AND HER FIRST PRESIDENT HAD THIS
AS A PART F HIS DNA THIS WAS
THE EMPHASIS INSTITUTION WHEN
SHE GRADUATED IN NINETEEN SIXTY
ONE SHE WAS NOT A TEACHER.
SHE WAS TRAINED AS A IN THE
HEALTH FIELD.
AND SHE ENDED UP COMING.
TO UC SAN FRANCISCO.
WHERE SHE WORKED IN THE CHILD?
OF PEDIATRIC CARDIOLOGY YOUR BUT
SHE WAS THERE IN THE SIXTIES.
AND UPON THE ASSASSINATION OF
MARTIN LUTHER KING.
THIS WOMAN WHO GOT A FREE PUBLIC
EDUCATION TO SCHOOL READ DOWN
FOR ITS ACCESS. TO EDUCATION
WITHOUT REGARD TO RACE OR OTHER
SORTS OF THINGS.
DECIDED SHE NEEDED TO BE A PART
OF THIS MOVEMENT.
SO SHE WENT TK HASTINGS LAW
SCHOOL GRADUATED WENT TO WORK AT
THE JERRY BROWN ADMINISTRATIONS
LEGAL ANALYST.
AND WAS APPOINTED TO MISS WILL
BE INSURANCE ACT WHEN A COUNTY
IN [inaudible]
NINETEEN EIGHTY THREE ARM.
MAKING HISTORY AS THE FIRST
BLACK FEMALE JUDGE.
IN SACRAMENTO.
WHEN SHE WENT ON THE MUNICIPAL
BENCH?
SHE WAS ELEVATED TO THE SUPERIOR
COURT.
IN.
NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT AND SERVED
AS THE ONLY AFRICAN AMERICANS
ARE CSUS UNTIL SHE RETIRED IN.
TWO THOUSAND TWO IN TWENTY
SIXTEEN GOVERNOR BROWN A POINTER
TO THE ATTORNEY GENERAL'S RACIAL
AND IDENTITY PROFILING ADVISORY
BOARD.
WHERE SHE SERVED UNTIL THIS PAST
FALL?
SO WE SEE THIS WOMAN WHOSE LIFE
WAS.
TOUCHED BY JERRY BROWN. ONE
POINT NO.
AND TO POINT OUT.
SHE WAS A LIFELONG READER AN
INTELLECTUAL.
ARE HER BROTHER HAD COMMENTED
THAT SHE KNEW HOW EDUCATION WAS
A ROAD.
OUT OF POVERTY.
AND AS HER BROTHER WHO TEACHES
IN SAN DIEGO COUNTY HIS SAID.
YEAH SHE WANT TO EXTEND THAT
FRANCHISE.
AND YOU SORT OF SEE THAT PLAYING
OUT ACROSS HER LIFE.
ALICE IS SURVIVED BY HER BROTHER
CECIL LYTLE HIS WIFE BETTY HER
BROTHERS.
HER BROTHER HENRY LYTLE SISTERS
QUINTAL OF LYTLE AUDREY JOHNSON
FORCE LASSITER.
NUMEROUS NIECES AND NEPHEWS.
AND ARM.
AS I SAY I'M JUST MOVE TODAY. TO
THINK ABOUT THE WORK WE DO.
THE POLICY IS TO PUT IN PLACE.
THE OPPORTUNITIES THEY OPEN UP
TO OTHER PEOPLE.
THIS MAGNIFICENT TRUTH OF LOCKS
MENTIS LUXOR BREAST.
LIGHT OF THE MIND.
LIGHT OF THE WORLD.
AND I JUST AS WE JOURNALISTS
LEVELS MEMORY PERSONIFIED ALL OF
THAT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER COOLEY AND
DOCTOR WEBER ON THIS GERMANY
MEMORY THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS I TO RISE --
AN ACID WITH GERMAN IN MEMORY OF
ALICE LYTLE --
A SUPERIOR COURT JUDGE EXCUSE ME
IN OF SUPERIOR COURT JUDGE HERE
IN SACRAMENTO --
ALICE WAS A TIRELESS THIS ANY
QUALITY.
AND A VERY DIFFERENT HER ENTIRE
FAMILY THE LYTLE FAMILY IS A
WELL KNOWN FAMILY IN CALIFORNIA
BECAUSE OF THE INVESTMENT THE
PARENTS MADE IN AND AND THEIR
CHILDREN AND MAKING SURE THE
CHILDREN WORK.
UPSTANDING CITIZENS AND HARD
WORKING AND MADE A DIFFERENCE
EVERYWHERE THEY WENT.
I MET AT ALICE THROUGH HER
BROTHER SEE SALIVA WHO'S A
CONCERT PIANIST AND EVENTUALLY
BECAME A A DEAN AND A VICE
PRESIDENT AND YOU SEE A STATE.
ALICE WAS CAREER WAS ONE OF
TREMENDOUS SERVICE AS THEY
TALKED ABOUT.
HOW SHE CAME TO BE A A SUPERIOR
COURT JUDGE AND AND WORKING VERY
HARD IN SACRAMENTO IN THE
MUNICIPAL COURT?
NEVER AFRAID OF CONTROVERSY
ALWAYS LOOKING FORWARD ALWAYS
DETERMINED TO MAKE A DIFFERENCE.
WHEN SHE STARTED THE LOCK A SEAT
AT WAS TALKED ABOUT IT WAS THE
HIGHLY CONTROVERSIAL PEOPLE DID
NOT WANT CHILDREN IN COURT ROOMS
THEY DID NOT WANT TO SEE YOUNG
CHILDREN?
RUNNING AROUND THE COURT ROOM SO
SHE OPENED UP A WAITING ROOM FOR
THEM FOR THE CHILDREN AND IT OF
COURSE IT WAS HIGHLY
CONTROVERSIAL WHY SHOULD WE
ACCOMMODATE THESE CHILDREN --
FOR WHETHER PARENTS ARE IN COURT
AND SHE RECOGNIZE THAT THIS WAS
AN EXTREMELY IMPORTANT PART IN
EXTENSION OF JUSTICE FOR THESE
INDIVIDUALS WERE WAITING FOR
THEIR CASES.
AS A RESULT NOW WE HAVE WAITING
FOR CHILDREN THROUGHOUT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA BECAUSE OF
HER SENSITIVITY TO THAT ISSUE.
SHE CARED DEEPLY ABOUT YOUNG
PEOPLE SO MUCH SO THAT SHE
RALLIED TO VARIOUS GROUPS FOR
TEENAGERS TO ADVOCATE FOR T.
THOSE WHO ARE PREGNANT IN THE
VARIOUS BIRTHING PROJECTS IN
THOSE KINDS OF THINGS.
THE SENSITIZER COURT TO THE CHAT
MAKE SURE THAT OUR NATION HAD
SOME SOME SENSE OF COMPASSION
FOR THEM.
SHE WAS A CHAMPION AND
EVERYTHING THAT WE TALKED ABOUT
SHE WAS DEALT WITH HEALTH ISSUES
OF TEENS OF MAKING SURE THAT
THEY UNDERSTOOD THEIR
RELATIONSHIP WITH OTHERS AND WHY
THEY NEED TO BE HEALTHY.
AND HOW THEY REALLY WERE THE
FIRST TEACHER OF CHILDREN TO
MAKE A DIFFERENCE IN THEIR LIVES.
THE LIFE LYTLE FAMILY IS A VERY
WELL KNOWN FAMILY IN ALICE LEADS
THAT FAMILY IN MANY WAYS BECAUSE
THEY REVIEW THEIR SISTER BECAUSE
SHE WAS SUCH AN ADVOCATE.
SHE HAD BEGUN HER LIFE THINKING
THAT SHE WOULD GOING TO
PEDIATRICS AND BECOME A DOCTOR.
WITH THE ASSASSINATION OF DR
KING SHE REALIZED A REAL PASSION
WITH SOCIAL JUSTICE.
THAT SHE NEEDED TO GO IN A
DIFFERENT DIRECTION THAN
MEDICINE AND THAT'S WHEN SHE
DECIDED TO GO TO LAW SCHOOL.
AND BECOME A JURIST SHE WAS
AMAZING IF YOU EVER MET HER SHE
WAS QUIET YET POWERFUL SHE FACED
A LOT OF CHALLENGES IN HER LIFE
BEING THE FIRST OF SO MANY
THINGS.
BEING RAISED IN HARLEM COMING
OUT OF THE SOUTH IN GOING IN
LIVING IN HARLEM WITH AT THE
TIME AND SHE LIVED THERE WAS A
VERY DIFFICULT TIME TO LIVE IN
HARLEM BECAUSE THERE WAS LOTS OF
A CRIME IN ACTIVITIES THAT
OCCURRED.
AND YET FOR HER HER FAMILY TOOK
FROM HARLEM THE BEST THAT IT HAD.
EDUCATION HUNTERS COLLEGE IT
TOOK THE MUSIC INDUSTRY FROM HER
BROTHER WHO BECAME A CONCERT
PIANIST THEY TOOK THE BEST OUT
OF HARLEM BECAUSE THEY SAW ALSO
MUCH GOOD IN HARLEM THAT COULD
THAT COULD HAPPEN FOR THEM AS
THEY CAME OUT OF THE SOUTH.
WHEN THEY DID THE SAME THING
WHEN THEY CAME TO CALIFORNIA
EVERYWHERE ALICE WENT SHE
CHANGED THE ENVIRONMENT THAT WAS
THERE?
IT'S AMAZING THAT HER LIFE
CIRCLED AROUND MINE IN SO MANY
WAYS FROM THE TIME I WAS A YOUNG
PROFESSOR AT SAN DIEGO STATE. TO
EVEN WITH MY BILL AB NINE FIVE
THREE THE APPOINTED TO THAT WHEN
I SAW HER NAME ON THAT I KNEW
THAT WHAT WOULD COME OUT OF THAT
COMMITTEE WOULD BE A QUALITY
WOULD BE SENSITIVE WOULD BE
CARING.
AND MOVES FORWARD AYE AYE AYE
ACID WE JOIN IN MEMORY OF ALICE
LYTLE.
OF MARI EVANS WON SAID NGUYEN IN
TERMS OF BLACK WOMEN HE SAYS
THEY ARE TALL AS A CYPRESS.
AND STRONG BEYOND ALL DEFINITION
ASSAILED IMPERVIOUS AN
INDESTRUCTIBLE AND THAT WAS OUR
SLIDESHOW SHE REALLY STOOD TALL
IN THE FIELD OF SOCIAL JUSTICE.
AND THOUGH THE CHALLENGES SHE
FACED NEVER DESTROYED HER BUT
MADE A HOPEFUL AND OPTIMISTIC
AND WE HAVE LOST A GIANT
CALIFORNIA BUT WE WERE BLESSED
WITH THE YEARS THAT SHE SERVICE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT WE JOIN
IN HER MEMORY.
THANK YOU DOCTOR WEBER.
MEMBERS PLEASE BRING THE NAMES
THE DESK TO BE PRINTED IN THE
JOURNAL.
ALL REQUEST TO ADJOURN IN MEMORY
WILL BE DEEMED READ AND PRINTED.
IN THE JOURNAL.
ALL OTHER ITEMS REMAINING WILL
BE PASSED RETAIN ALL MOTIONS
SHALL BE CONTINUE.
SEEING HEARING OF FOR THE
BUSINESS I'M READY TO ENTERTAIN
A MOTION TO ADJOURN.
MISTER COOLEY MOVES AND DOCTOR
WEBER SECONDS.
AT THIS HOUSE STANDS ADJOURNED
UNTIL MONDAY FEBRUARY ELEVENTH
AT ONE PM WE ARE JR [inaudible]
THANK